hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and  while all the cool kids are doing their  Nexus 6 and Nexus 9 videos and I'm still  waiting for mine I figured I'd do a sort  of a video that's a little bit different  from my normal style if there is such a  thing a couple of days ago I posted on  Instagram that I was looking for an  adventure because we just gotten the  GoPro Hero 4 and we found one so shout  out to freshmen this isn't a full review  video of the camera by any means but  it's more of a fun clip showing what a  small lightweight camera like a GoPro is  capable of even if your life isn't full  of BASE jumping and skydiving and crazy  surfing and stuff like that so this is  the GoPro Hero 4 this is Mac and this is  just being the dog in 4k  you